as soon as that mask went on i don't
know the [ __ ] just came out of me
being cheated on is awful enough now
imagine having to play lovers with the
person who cheated on you
which two actors fell in love and got
divorced all throughout one series
together
some actors refused to work with others
due to allegations and some just don't
vibe very well
whatever the reason we've got the scoop
on some of the most intense hollywood
working relationships
or not working that is sometimes i'm
totally overwhelmed
i'm overwhelmed if you make two people
who detest each other work together and
pretend to be a couple
will they fall in love the chances
aren't so good for reese witherspoon and
vince vaughn
the two did not get along filming for
christmases and judging from some of
these glares
yeah things were tense ever wonder why
vaughn didn't do any promotion for the
movie
simple answer he disliked working with
witherspoon so much he couldn't stand to
spend any time with her he didn't
absolutely have to
you know find that balance for yourself
when you get involved and when you don't
while wahlberg and dicaprio appeared in
the departed together this pair almost
never worked together dicaprio was cast
in a film called the basketball diaries
and when he learned that a certain mark
wahlberg was supposed to do it as well
he completely freaked out and said he
wouldn't do the movie
leo didn't get his way but the two ended
up working things out in the end and
even became pals
thank goodness because their on-screen
chemistry is great
you accept me as your friend sure thanks
pam and you
i as well these two had quite an
interesting time filming the movie this
is the end together
neither actor had a very big part and
they were playing themselves in the
movie but
it seems that tatum got a little too
comfortable there was a scene that never
made the final cut because it involved
tatum dancing around in this
very particular outfit while he was on
set he thought it would be fun to move
to watson and dance in front of her
watson was not a fan and was so upset by
it that she walked off the set
not only that but she walked away from
the film fully and didn't return after
the incident
the work day was done five minutes after
her exit the team had enough footage of
watson for the film to make sense
overall so they kept that and rewrote
the remainder of what she would have
been in
ultimately had to actually go and do it
but that was a terrible idea probably
while they played besties with loads of
tension on gossip girl the fact is that
their real-life relationship was just as
intense
you did not just do that why do you
think you were invited
meester thought lively was full of
herself since she was cold with her
castmates and didn't really show the
enthusiasm others on the team did
lively's rep was pretty honest and said
that the two had never really been
friends and that the show was just a job
lively just did her job even today the
two don't follow each other on instagram
so it actually makes it a lot harder but
it makes the performance
holistically so much more gal gadot
reportedly refused to reprise her role
in wonder woman as wonder woman
unless brett ratner was fired from the
project after six women came forward
accusing ratner of sexual assault
godot demanded he be fired from the
production and since she's wonder woman
well the team came together and honored
godot's demand
you know they all have echoed the same
sentiments
it would have made total sense for braun
and circe to interact in game of thrones
but they never did share the screen
once upon a time when they were dating
it probably wouldn't have been an issue
but
once they broke up they didn't want to
have anything to do with each other and
couldn't even be in the same room
together on set
what tell everyone the truth this was
one of the more legendary stories
it was actually known that the two
should be kept apart for everybody's
sake
what's left to fight for lindsay lohan's
character on the show ugly betty was
actually meant to have a longer run on
the show but let's just say
if lowen had stayed things could have
gotten even uglier
lohan was in her prime days then and had
a bit of a diva streak
trashing dressing rooms refusing to show
up on set ferreira was
not having it while it was tense from
the beginning the day that really went
wrong was one where they rehearsed a
scene where ferrero was supposed to be
pantsed by lohan
america jokingly did it to lohan on set
and well lohan was a bit underdressed
for the occasion
she was embarrassed to tears by the
incident the experience wasn't great for
either of them so it's no surprise they
never appeared on screen together again
wesley snipes was without a doubt the
least liked person on the set of blade
trinity
ryan reynolds had one of the worst
experiences with this
and since they played opposite each
other it was hard to avoid
this is supposed to be a rough year
snipes acted really erratically on set
and did questionable things like
communicating with the director through
only
post-it notes don't worry about it
at all here we have another example of
tv couple goals we loved but
unfortunately
this one wasn't such a happy ever after
they went through falling in love
getting married and a messy divorce all
while playing leads in the popular
series one tree hill together
murray definitely screwed up when he
cheated on bush with paris hilton
only a month after he got married we
wouldn't want to work with murray after
that either
that's right do you know why
ally and noah were couple goals for the
longest time
if you're a bird i'm a bird right the
early days definitely resembled these
intense fights between the two though
stay with you what for look at us we're
already fighting well that's what we do
gosling was actually so frustrated
working with mcadams one day that he
publicly asked the director if another
actress could replace her offscreen
because he couldn't work with her
anymore
they managed to work through their
differences anyway and ended up dating
for a while after the fact
this has not been my experience but i
hear that it happens
remember how the actor who played on
vivian and fresh prince of bel air
suddenly looked
very different janet hubert was replaced
by daphne reed in 1993 who played the
role until the end of the series
there are a couple of different sides to
this story hubert claimed that the cast
was really cruel and unkind to her
smith says that that wasn't quite the
case and blamed hubert's negative
attitude
either way hubert said she would never
work with him again calling him an
egomaniac
surprisingly though in 2020 they did
reunite and address the long-running
feud
i felt like you hated me
this seems like a bit of an unlikely
pair to have such a tense relationship
but
neither one is a fan of the other looks
like ford didn't have to do too much
acting while he played hartnett's
partner in the movie hollywood homicide
ford called hartnett a punk and hartnett
retaliated with the oh so mature
comeback of
old fart it was pretty inconvenient
considering they both played leading
roles
there were times they actually just sat
on set in silence because they were so
infuriated with each other
if i like the people that i might be
potentially working with i just want to
take
i want to take the opportunity james
franco has a strong personality
and well let's just say he's clashed
with a few colleagues over the years
his method acting style didn't go over
so well tyreese gibson who started
receiving
actual punches from franco while they
were doing the film annapolis together
while franco denies ever hitting him he
admits he was probably a jerk but that
he never wanted to work with gibson
again
we're pretty positive gibson wouldn't
want to work with him either
many many years ago jennifer aniston and
leslie mann appeared in a film called
she's the one together
let's just say aniston wants to keep
that experience
way back in the past even though the
actress really wants to work with judd
apatow again
the thing keeping them apart is his wife
man since she appears in most of his
films
it seems there are a few other people on
anniston's side
since man is known for having
difficulties with the leading ladies in
her husband's films
i would just feel good to be like to
hurt people it didn't take very long for
faye and hilton to clash when they
worked together on an episode of snl
that hilton hosted
according to faye hilton was way too
much of a diva to work with
and on top of not being a very good host
she also made fun of actors for their
weight and was rude to everyone
fae is confirmed that she'd never work
with her again after that nightmare
wow these are awkward just to hear about
we can't even imagine having to work on
sets with people we have such strained
relationships with
the actors definitely did show off their
skills though when they managed to
continue working together despite these
rageful feelings
did any of these feuds surprise you